اوهمهم بان الجوع والامتناع عن الطعام
نهائيا سيدخلهم الجنه
صدقه البسطاء وصاروا خلف مزاعمه الشيطانيه
لكن مصيرهم باتا يتمثل في هذه الاكفان مات
اغلبهم بعد التطور جوعا املين ان يشفع لهم
هذا الجوع في الخلود والنعيم كما اوهمهم
بول ماكينزي الدجال في ثوب رجل الدين
في ابريل من عام 2023 اثرت الشرطه على
مقبره جماعيه في غابه شاكا هولا شرقي
كينيا حشرات الجثث التي لقيت حدفها بسبب
الجوع والمتهم هذا الرجل الذي قيل انه
اقنع اتباعه بتجويع انفسهم حتى الموت
كطريق للوصول الى الجنه لكن عندما علمت
السلطات بما وقع ويقع من هذا الرجل
سارعوا لانقاذ ما يمكن انقاذه
البشاعه هذا المنظر تخفي شخصيه شيطانيه
قامت بعمل لا يقل ارهابا عن عمليات القتل
العمد كما وصفه المسؤولون الكينيون حتى
الاطفال لم يسلموا من هذه الكارثه الرئيس
الكينيتهم باستخدام دين الارتكاب مواصفه
بالافعال الشنيعه مشددا على تسريع
التحقيقات وبيان ادله ادانته من اجل
محاكمته
رغم ان كل اصابع الاتهام تشير الى انه
ينكر صلته بما وقع لهؤلاء البسطاء مؤكدا
انه قد اغلق الكنيسه منذ عام 2019
ستقوم السلطات بتحليل عينات من الحمض
النووي للتاكد من طبيعه الوفاه وما اذا
كان الضحايا قد توفوا نتيجه الجوع وبين
النفي والاثبات بالتحقيقات لم يخسر في هذه
الماساه سوى هؤلاء الضحايا فقدوا حياتهم
بسبب اوهام لا اساس لها واعدادهم بلغت حتى
الان نحو 200 ضحيه
وما زال البحث مستمرا عن المزيد من
المقابر